strata we need to talk
really we there is a huge debate and we
need to put an end to it and I mean
people don't know where to put their
commas I'm talking about sequel I'm sure
most of you must love sequel
I love sequel it's born in 1978 and it's
the one language with the best thing we
have when we want to analyze analyze
data but it's not perfect most of you
must have learned sequel with a sentence
like this this is how you get one column
of data this is how you get two columns
then you glow for three and suddenly
things don't work what's wrong here that
extra comma yes you've been there sequel
would not allow you to put a hanging
chrome at the end unlike any other
modern language and this has driven
people to two different camps there are
people that put the comma at the end
people that put their commas at the
beginning who likes their comments at
the end who likes their commas at the
beginning you monsters that's ugly
well I'm one of you I like to put my
comments at the beginning I find it's
more productive but it's hard to
convince people about this
so I happen to work at Google where we
make decisions based on data also I work
for Google cloud platform where we share
our best tools with everyone so things
that we use internally you are also able
to use and one of them is bigquery with
the query we can analyze not only
terabytes of data in seconds we are also
able to share data with within our
teammates within third parties publicly
and we love using it to collaborate to
discuss to take the same data and reach
conclusions together in this case for
example I have all of get cos datastore
DB query and we
where you live like this I can see how
many events github has seen this year
360 million events I can join this table
with other tables I can bring in for
example count the number of distinct
users active users this year and I can
bring another table to see where are
they coming from what are the most
popular countries on github the United
States China India which we would call
an unfair ranking I mean these are the
biggest countries of course they have
the most users so let's bring in more
tables let's bring in more data let's
get the countries that have the most
github users per capita and now we have
countries like Iceland Sweden Norway on
top cold countries or not so now we can
bring in more data we can join this with
the world where weather data that we
have in and we can get a chart like this
which shows that yes the coldest
countries up on the top left are the
ones with the highest concentration of
programmers the opposite on the other
side but if you look at that point on
the top right
that's Singapore yes Singapore you have
the highest concentration of programmers
on github within the hot countries
congratulations but let me get back to
our problem where do we put our commas
and this is not Tubbs versus two spaces
this really matters and I'm going to
bring in all code I can find on github
I'm going to analyze a gigabytes of
sequel code and I will use it to count
the number of lines that end with a
comma start with a comma and the results
show that most lines and with a comma
I lost or not because the real question
is what projects are more successful how
do we measure that the number of stars
the number of stars last year the number
of contributors the activity etc etc we
define our success metrics and we can
measure and we can write a query we can
get the results in seconds and it
basically says that projects that allow
leading people to write lead in comas
double as productive as the others it's
true you can go and measure it in any
dimension you want thank you yes you
were the link chromosome so my message
here is that mania will not stop all
fights because I'm sure I didn't
convince everyone here someone will ask
about correlation causation how do you
are you measuring these why an average
and the whole point is that you can find
me you can use the same tools you can
use the same queries and data and
analyze it and find me some people will
never convince no matter how much data
we show them we call them into three
analysts sorry but yes at least we
should embrace data in this fight